Imagine, you're a computational biologist who just
got a job at 23andMe. Congratulations, and now
you're working on their ancestry and relative finder
features. Your job is to create algorithms to
determine identity by descent or IBD scores.
To see how related two people might be.
Remember we learned about IBD in lesson 11.
In writing your code you see an example
that gives you pause. In one comparison you
see two people who share short segments of
five different chromosomes. All about the same size.
But in a different comparison with two different people,
you see a comparison that shows one long
shared segment from just one chromosome. It's about twice
the size of the segments from the other
comparison. So as you continue to write your code,
which of these scenarios should be ranked as more related? Which of them
shows a closer relationship? The individuals with
five shared short segments, or the individuals
with the one shared longer segment. I want you to pick which answer
you think is best, and then tell me why in the text box here.